previously on model lifestyle today I'm
doing a TV commercial which is one of
the best jobs that you can get as a
model but more jobs just came flying in
and I went from one job to the other and
before I knew it I was on the way home
to Pretoria in South Africa finally I am
back home and I cannot wait to see my
beautiful wife again hi if this is your
first time on my channel subscribe and
hit the bell so you won't miss the next
video
[Music]
my flight just arrived in South Africa
and Nikita is waiting for me at the
arrivals now before I meet my wife let
me introduce you to South Africa the
beautiful country where I grew up there
is over 55 million people that live in
South Africa but sadly 26% of them are
unemployed
some countries have deserts some have
subtropical forests right well South
Africa has deserts wetlands grasslands
bush subtropical forests mountains and
escarpment we have both the Atlantic and
the Indian Ocean which holds various
kinds of sea life and beautiful coastal
cities like our famous kata
we have beautiful rivers and wild
animals like lions elephants and even
penguins but the truth is that under all
this beauty is a sad an ugly side of
South Africa which is crime like the
Rhino that is slowly becoming extinct
because heartless criminals killed over
seven thousand rhinos over the last few
years just to sell their horns and apart
from the Rhino issue our government is
unbelievably cool wrong we have over 50
murders in South Africa every day but
that's enough for now let's get back to
the story
so finally I came back to Nikita after
three months
[Music]
first thing we did is we had some state
because oh man
South Africa has the best food in world
well according to my perception man it
was so good to see her again
[Applause]
[Music]
we got in the car and we drove back home
and I could not wait to sleep after a
whole day of traveling
[Music]
and when I saw her Dokdo go again I
couldn't believe how big he's got he's
definitely not a puppy anymore
I remember the first day when we got him
Wow how time flies
you are so little so cute
[Music]
go go go
[Music]
now when you travel for work as a model
there's a lot of things that change over
time and every time when you come back
home you see just how much you haven't
missed out the next day I called my
mother agency to start planning my next
contract hey Laura is Daniel here how
are you good good good good yeah I just
arrived back home yeah yeah Nikita's
good everything is fine yeah mm-hmm
yeah so I just wanted to ask you about
the the auctions for my next contract
and yeah ah so Japan is interested okay
mm-hmm okay Laura can you also ask yeah
a few more yeah more options good
all right cool so I'll speak to you in a
few days then all right okay thank you
appreciate it
all right okay bye
so while my mother agency is looking
into the options for my next modeling
contract I spend my time with family
we had a real South African braai in my
language which is Afrikaans we call a
barbecue at dry
[Music]
[Music]
nice mushrooms violin
[Music]
right break-in car yep mushroom just
like mice
[Music]
now you are looking at our traditional
dessert we call it from all folk we're
spending time with family after not
seeing them for a long time which is
really good for me but I also had to
catch up on my responsibilities at home
like working in the garden we moved into
this house recently so that Nikita can
stay here while she completes her degree
in interaction design I did not have a
lot of time to really work on the house
so now I have to do what a man's gotta
do
[Music]
some nights I made some food for me and
Nikita because she had a lot of work to
do from college I did not mind at all I
had free time because I'm still waiting
to hear from my agency about the next
modeling contract one of our favorite
things to do together is to watch a good
TV series and when I have more free time
I also like to play online games I am at
my brother's house and we are playing a
game called heroes and Generals I've
been playing games with my brother since
we were little and this is something we
like to do together when we have time
[Music]
being away from home a lot causes me to
miss special days like birthdays or
anniversaries and so on but today I am
home for Father's Day now sadly my
father passed away from cancer last year
and it is still a really hard for me
because I'm missing a lot my
father-in-law is now the only that I
have left and we went to spend time with
him on Father's Day and as you can see
these gates and fences is part of South
Africa's living conditions because of
the crime so most people try to stay in
protected housing with security yeah I
know it's quite insane places like this
might seem like it is in the middle of
nowhere but it is actually a big piece
of land that is highly protected by
security so here we can let our guard
down and relax
[Music]
the time flew by and every now and then
I would drop my kid off at college but
today something crazy happened again in
South Africa they say they say anything
under under more than 100 taxis have
arrived in Madrid this could see major
traffic delays and routes out of Madrid
towards Kempton Park later this morning
housing police spokesperson chemical
Bella says taxi drivers are allowed to
gather in Madrid only until their time
event pretended that it didn't 9/11 and
as you can see it is not easy to live in
South Africa anymore finally the day
came when my mother agency called me
with the options for my next modeling
contract hey Laura how are you good good
thank you
yeah mm-hmm okay
all right though so yeah
okay so Japan maybe later the year okay
so I can either go to Malaysia or Cape
Town that's the best for right now yeah
all right okay well yeah
yeah I think so too okay I think I'll
choose
hi if this is your first time on my
channel subscribe and hit the bell so
you won't miss the next video
[Music]
you
you